well Seattle police are searching for
the motive of a man who went on a deadly
shooting rampage during rush hour in the
city investigators say the gunman shot
at several drivers and tried to carjack
multiple vehicles two people were killed
and two others were hurt DeMarco Morgan
shows us the scary ordeal for commuters
unsuspecting drivers on the Seattle
Street encountered a hell of gunfire
around 4:00 p.m. it didn't matter who
you were he was gonna shoot you if he
saw you after a man carrying a handgun
began shooting I turned around left as
he was heading right for me and I barely
got out of there it was close real close
the 33 old unnamed suspect began its
rampage by shooting a 57 year-old woman
during a carjacking attempt she survived
then police say he took aim at a city
bus this bus driver truly is a hero
bus driver Eric stark took all 12
passengers to safety after a bullet hit
him in the chest he was able to have the
wherewithal to put the bus in Reverse
back it up turn it around which is no
easy feat in and of itself
the gunman moved on to another car and
killed the driver the suspect climbed
into the victim's car in sped away
during a nearly half mile police chase
the shooter collided with another car
killing the 17 year old driver after
standoff police dragged him from the
wrecked car and took him into custody
this is you know scary seeing this kind
of stuff happened just how it's at your
house
the gunman was taken to the hospital
after the wreck for CBS this morning
tomorrow morning